good afternoon it's a real pleasure to
be at Yale I and I look very forward
very much forward to our session this
afternoon the morning one was really
excellent and I think Holmes has
established the platform for what I want
to say in fact I think just to recap by
2070 or so if we want to achieve two
degrees stabilization of climate the two
degrees by 27 years so emissions have to
be zero and that means they have to peek
very soon and if they don't and if there
are 0 later we will need negative
emissions and that is all the technology
story in a broader sense it's about
institutions it's about technologies
that we need so I will focus a little
bit about what we would need to do in
the technology area to achieve the
two-degree future we need a emergence
and diffusion of new and disruptive
technologies that will be the point of
my presentation but before one can
contemplate the future and I'm doing it
in exactly in the sense that Neil said
this morning and homes now scenarios not
projections the scenarios about possible
futures and what we need to do now to
understand the future we have to
understand the pass and here you have
the dynamics of the energy system over
the past what I show here is the
percentage of how different energy forms
are reaching the consumer it used to be
all solid coal and wood noncommercial
energy then you can see that liquids
came in fifty percent of them go into
the into the transport sector and now
grids which is electricity gas and
perhaps in the future hydrogen the point
I would like to make is if you look at
the 15 20 year period not that much
happens the inertia in the system is
huge but if you look over a period of 50
or 60 years then huge changes can occur
so maybe it's possible to reverse the
system by 2070 and the question is how
and I would like to show you one
scenario from the global energy
assessment that was concluded last year
with 300 experts around the world and it
involved developing many alternative
scenarios over 40 that reach the
two-degree target but they also reach
full access to energy services by the
humanity and I was really happy to see a
number of posters dealing with the lack
of access and how to improve that now
this is one of many but it shows you
that the system has to change
fundamentally really fundamentally and
many of these scenarios goat over the
gridded energy because it's more
convenient and cleaner and that means
lots of energy gases but in in
particular huge amount of electricity
now to convince you that we cannot
predict the single technology I would
like to show you a graph from Granger
Morgan it shows a number of energy end
users from railways to aeroplanes cars
information technology industrial
production now look how fundamental the
change has been on the periods of 50
years and in such a way that it's
completely unpredictable if you think
about 1900 some of the most prominent
scientists before the turn of the
century said heavier than then air
flying machines are not possible and we
had them and we all travel in them now
here's a picture of how it might look in
the future I'm just putting something
there to give you an impression it can
indeed be really radically different
from super grids all the way down to
machines that produce machines that
replicate themselves self-organizing
production so i think it is we have to
think in those terms and so how could
that happen well here is an illustration
very schematic the yellow line if you
can see it shows an incremental current
technology at that time from the
perspective of 1900 that did not improve
all that much horse horse horses and
carriages are really exciting story of
technology improvement but over the last
hundred years the improvement was not
all that great but at the same time
people were breaking their heads about
how could we transform the system there
were many designs many of them never
actually survived the first tests in the
market until about 20 20s or 30s but the
automobiles that started as a horseless
carriage did make it and they change the
world but not they themselves alone but
in conjunction with the other
technologies so what we need is systems
not single technologies we need systems
and here is an example i justjust these
pictures are more legislation of the
narrative that i would like to propose
here here you see the same thing the
learning curves like before this is the
unit cost of the number of technologies
and this one just to help you on the
logarithmic scale so it looks linear on
horizontal scale is the cumulative
capacity this red curve is the
photovoltaics and we all here I hope
later on about photovoltaics but look
how great the stories to two men orders
of magnitude reduction in costs just
absolutely incredible with of course
many magnitudes of doubling of the
energy market so that today
photovoltaics are almost competitive but
we have a number of other technologies
that are doing the same thing this
corresponds roughly to twenty percent
cost reduction per doubling of the
global cumulative capacity now there are
two to two other technologies that did
not experience cost improvements so we
can also forget but not doing not just
learn by doing and this in this case
this is US nuclear and France nuclear
costs going up so in my view this is the
key issue in many ways with the
acceptability of the nuclear and I'll be
interested to see your comments so we
have a challenge there we really have a
challenge that we can achieve this
across a wide range of technologies and
they can converge into systems that will
reduce the emissions towards zero and so
let me try to illustrate where I think
the emphasis should be on the systems in
the future on the vertical scale you see
again the learning costs so about twenty
to thirty percent learning predominant
of the capacity for the green
technologies and what are they they are
relatively granule there they are things
like memory chips telephones
refrigerators even cars with those kinds
of technologies you have quick lifetimes
we can replace replace the car fleet in
about 30 years computers on the on the
time scale of 56 years and so these are
the technologies where you can have very
large learning but if you look at the
energy supply the picture is not that
nice because these technologies change
relatively slowly so it's the
infrastructures
energy supply that provide this inertia
and that are inhibiting the change in
many ways but again for the
photovoltaics that's the red curve here
they're granular so it's one of the few
supplied technologies it actually can
change very rapidly now I just
illustrate to you how disruptive the
change could be from google I'm not
saying this will happen but as you know
they're planning completely alternative
wind technologies and i'm sure you'll
talk about photovoltaics but really
really lots of lots of different ideas
this idea i like a lot it's under ocean
storage of electricity for an
intermittent wind on the ocean and we
are no doubt going that direction or a
platforms with wind just like we do with
oil and gas now in the mobility area
it's the same this is the car I Drive
but this is not disruptive that's the
point we have to really keep in mind
this is an incremental technology we
have replaced hear the engine with the
electric drive like we have replaced
horses with with an engine the turn of
the last century so this is also not
incremental this is a hybrid fuel cell
electric bus but both of those
technologies bring zero emissions if you
produce electricity with zero emission
so it's great but here is a little bit
more disruptive but also fun this is a
study of Toyota how future mobility
might look like and then we have to
worry about buildings it is possible to
reduce the energy in buildings by ninety
percent this is a house in Czech
Republic building the under the old
system with planning and then
retrofitted ninety percent reduction if
we do fifty percent reduction that's
already will get us a long way toward
our goal and then we will need
infrastructures that's the toughest this
is the backbone of our energy system I
would like to illustrate here the idea
of a super grid connecting remote energy
sources whether their nuclear or
renewable to big urban centers in Asia
because that's going to be the future
hub and then there is a magnetic
levitation train I'm a big fan of that
as well and so together with the smart
kids so you need the system and that's
paradigm change so to conclude I will
want to quote schumpeter you know I
think he has made the point very vivid
that just combining technologies you
don't get new systems we did not go from
mail coaches to railways simply by
aggregation we had to do something
fundamentally different and then these
new technologies have to be nurtured
this is why R&D is a big issue but also
early investment in the market we are
investing on the order of 150 billion a
year in the early experimental phase
where you reduce the technology costs
very highly that's way too little by
very very large factor and then let me
conclude you have seen this already it
appeared from nowhere earlier but I just
wanted I just wanted to finish this by
one of my favorite sketches if you
notice here this is from 1928 the chart
in 1926 we already had steam railways
and mr. Henry parmer was much more
sustainable he thought that the monorail
would go with Hibbert horses and wind
would have been a great technology did
not work out but the vision is right and
he was very successful so that's
optimistic note I want to end them he
was exceedingly successful because he
was the greatest designer of monorails
of course he shifted to steam at the end
and electricity but he had the right
vision so I think it's important to have
a vision how we get there is a more
complicated story thank you
you